what do you think of people that move
here because you did move here you were
waiting for maybe to find another job
and they wait to be picked it sounds
like you don't wait to be picked for
things you just do them yeah no people
who move out here have to really have a
lot of zeal in their heart in this
spirit they have to really go for it you
can't come out here and just kind of
like do the run of the mill the run of
the mill auditions and just headshots
and that you have to really find avenues
to like it's like driving in traffic you
got to find a way to swerve and moving
it out and dip and switch lanes and get
ahead of people you really have to work
hard you can't wait to be picked you
cannot you have to do it yourself when I
got along the roadside when that came
across to me I didn't want to just do a
Taylor a filmed audition and just read
the script I wanted to shoot my audition
that way and then also film it like an
actual scene in the movie so they can
pitch me in the role you know I just
wanted to take a step further so you
really have to hustle you play Barney I
play Barney and Barney's going through
some stuff yeah Barney is a little bit
on the run you know he kind of considers
himself a sailor who's left one shore
but hasn't yet reached the next so he's
still kind of floating and drifting and
he's got a lot on his mind you know
because of some things that's going on
with him and his girlfriend and that
takes him pretty far or pushes him
pretty far I should say you know and to
his drift you know for someone that went
to performing arts school like you did
and is hoping to come out here or to New
York and and go on that whole like
audition treadmill I see it in people
and I know that some days they're elated
when I see them and other days they seem
pretty down so what would you say to
those people like you said that you
wouldn't advise someone to just stick to
that audition route if they want to say
well I don't have a camera or I don't
know how to edit with Adobe or a Final
Cut Pro you know I don't have anybody to
shoot a webseries with like what's your
because I hear that a lot or when I
become famous I'm gonna have people
upload my stuff to YouTube but not right
now what do you say to those people that
want someone to do it for them and just
want to do that normal route that a lot
of
have learned that's the way you do yeah
it's there's nothing wrong with
traditional route of auditioning I
audition you know I love auditioning and
I want to get further into that circuit
and you know cuz auditioning is a route
that I haven't needed to use yet but
it's something now that I'm seeking
after because I want to do traditional
Hollywood work however building your own
audience can help get you into a lot of
rooms though I've gotten a lot of
auditions just because people see me
online and so what I would say to those
people who don't say you don't have a
camera you don't have it that's fine but
you can still at least you have a phone
you know you can take pictures and you
know upload the Instagram upload the
Facebook or snapchat or just anything to
help build your presence online so then
when I see you you know what about the
people that are afraid of being too
maybe they're afraid that they're gonna
look too boastful to people and they
don't want to be the ones promoting
themselves they want someone to promote
them it's I mean that to me sounds kind
of self-defeating you're mean if you're
gonna be in an entertainment business
you have to promote just entertainment
so that's like it comes in the package
you're an entertainment you have to
promote yourself you have to not only
audition when you're in the room but you
have to kind of audition at all times
it's like for instance a friend of mine
is a fighter
and you know someone suggested that he
should never drink because he's trying
to get a new fight and he could get a
call at any moment so at any moment
someone could come calling for me and if
I'm not on top of my game and like
promoting myself and like working on my
craft and just putting myself out there
all times you know you never know you
might miss opportunity so a man once
told me always just be ready always be
ready always be ready because you never
don't want to call them coming you never
know when an audition is gonna come in
so part of that package is always
promoting yourself always being on you
know and just being ready for the call
to come in do you have time to hang out
with friends or are you doing more yes I
do yeah I have time to hang out friends
are okay always make time for leisure
sure little R&R I do but the more that I
focus though it is it does get harder
because it's like I push myself to focus
more because I like to go out and and
with my friends but you have to you
gotta stay focus and the more focused I
am the harder I work the less time I
have to hang out you know I have to say
no to parties sometimes because you know
there's more important things to do do
you see other people getting caught up
in that where they want to I mean we all
want to have a circle of friends around
us but yeah it's inspiring
I do see other people get caught up in
that and it's inspiring because I have
friends who are on TV and that's where I
want to be and you know when they have
lines to read or they have a rehearsal
the next day or if they have a shoulder
for the next day they don't go out you
know and I barely see them and then
every time I do see them they're like I
got to go home and study lines and while
some people might think that's boring
for me that's inspiring because it's
like the proofs in the pudding they're
home working but they're also in a TV
show so who cares about free time or who
cares about going out when you could be
on a show and be studying lines and
living a dream
you